one of the questions that is
increasingly being asked about the legal
defense being mounted after the FBI raid
of Mar-A-Lago to get all those documents
back from Donald Trump is are Trump's
lawyers going to use the same stupid
arguments that they're making on TV when
it comes to courts of law because if
they do it's going to be very
embarrassing for them I'm going to give
you one such example here is Trump
attorney Christina Bob who was on
Newsmax of two days ago I believe it was
and she started making the case that the
raid was illegal
and that it's unconstitutional and that
privileged documents were taken it's a
very dumb argument is she willing to
make it in court or do they only make
these Arguments for the court of public
opinion on TV I don't know that anything
about this raid was legal but uh they
did take attorney-client documents and
we know that because in the warn in the
receipt of property that they gave us
they actually gave us two separate
receipts of property one of them is a
shorter list I think it only has about
five or six items on it and then you've
got the other one that has the I don't
know 20 or so items on it and uh the
shorter list which doesn't explain that
it's privileged information they just
happen to tell me that when they gave me
the receipt they said this is privileged
information that you know we're handling
it differently you know we'll work out
with the lawyers how to handle it but of
course you know they write out
classified information on the one list
and then when they take something that
is questionable and the public won't
like they leave that off of the list and
just tell me so I think it's a lot of
games manship I think what they did is
wrong it's illegal it's unconstitutional
and I think they have a lot of
explaining to do now if you I've read a
couple of legal opinions about this and
other arguments that are being made by
by Trump's legal team of Haba Bob it's
Alina Haba and Christina Bob
um
lawyers are basically laughing like it's
saying okay sure you can say that on TV
to try to convince people that what took
place was wrong but these are not really
Arguments for court and it's very
similar to what happened with Cassidy
Hutchinson similar not exactly the same
remember that Cassidy Hutchinson was
this Aid to Trump's former Chief of
Staff Mark Meadows and she testified
under oath before the January 6
Committee in the House of
Representatives and under oath she made
a number of assertions about Secret
Service about Trump's desires on the day
of uh the riots and on and on and on
immediately after that
you heard media reports of Secret
Service agents supposedly claiming that
Cassidy Hutchinson was lying and saying
they'd be willing to give the true side
of the story
and then they never did and they were
invited and they were welcomed and the
door was wide open from the House of
Representatives for those Secret Service
agents and others who said Chris sorry
Cassidy Hutchinson not Christina Bob
Cassidy Hutchinson is lying to come in
and make those claims under oath and
they never did and often a strategy is
well we don't want to lie under oath so
we will lie in the court of public
opinion we will lie in the media and
then as consumers we have to think and
say okay Cassidy Hutchinson was under
oath
in the House of Representatives all of
these other media statements are not
under oath and we're not even hearing it
directly from the horse's mouth
oftentimes there are reports of
statements that are being made let's not
consider that equivalent
and so when we think about oh the
legality of the search warrant
everything we know factually looking at
the search warrant the affidavit knowing
that it was signed off on by Merit
Garland knowing that it was signed off
on by Christopher Ray the FBI director
selected by Donald Trump knowing it was
signed off on by a judge that's
substantive reason to believe that the
raid was perfectly legal you then have a
lawyer
on TV saying it was illegal and
unconstitutional okay well these are not
equivalent make that argument in court
is what Christina Bob should do my guess
is that that's not where they're going
to be bringing this argument I want to
remind you uh once again that on 9 19 we
are doing our 919 David packman show
membership special it will be 19 themed
and if you've been thinking well maybe
I'll dabble in membership a little bit
of membership never hurt anybody uh you
can get on my mailing list at
davidpackman.com and then on the morning
of 9 19 Like a Phoenix rising over the
horizon you will receive an email
telling you exactly how to take
advantage of this great membership
special in the meantime let me know on
Twitter at dpacman will Trump's lawyers
make these silly arguments in a court or
are they only willing to make them on TV
plastic is everywhere we look and not
enough is being done about it 100
billion plastic bags are used and thrown
away every year but you can help make a
change our sponsor hold on makes trash
and kitchen bags that are heavy duty
plant-based non-toxic and 100 home
compostable which means they break down
in weeks rather than decades they don't
fill up our landfills they don't pollute
our oceans they're zip seal kitchen bags
come in sandwich or gallon bag sizes to
fit your needs and the best part about
hold on bags is they work I use them at
home they're just as good as all of the
name brand bags you fill them up they
stretch and they don't break everybody
uses trash bags and freezer bags if you
care about the planet you can do
something by using hold on bags instead
and it's a really easy way to do your
part to shop plant-based bags and
replace single-use Plastics all over
your home go to hold on bags.com and
you'll save twenty percent with the code
Pacman at checkout the link is down
below